[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 l'actualité locale
et régionale en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de ce mardi 10
avril trois jours de visites conférences
et tables rondes le salon des maires
d'île de france a été inauguré ce matin
à paris il réunit l'ensemble des
décideurs locaux autour de
problématiques rencontrées par les
collectivités territoriales dans cette
édition entretiens sur place avec
plusieurs élus yvelinois et franciliens
une bibliothèque anatomiques en trois
dimensions procédés innovants à
destination des étudiants de
masso-kinésithérapie malvoyants
l'objectif c'est de les aider à mieux se
former le projet a été développé par une
association et la fondation et dassault
systems basé à vélizy et puis retour sur
la cinquième édition de la fête de la
petite enfance elle se tenait samedi
dernier à trappes une journée ludique un
moment d'information pour les parents
auprès des professionnels invités de ce
journal le comité valentin hauy à des
yvelines l'association organise ce
samedi à versailles une après-midi
thématique sur les avancées
technologiques et médicale pour les
déficients visuels
on en parle tout à l'heure dans ce
journal il sait donc que ouvert ce matin
à paris porte de la villette la 22e
édition du salon des maires à d'île de
france se tient jusqu'à jeudi
inauguration avec le ministre de la
cohésion des territoires jacques mézard
et la présidente de la région en valérie
pécresse
le salon ces trois jours de conférences
tables rondes notamment en présence de
l'ensemble des prestataires des
collectivités territoriales élus experts
et techniciens se réunissent autour de
grands thèmes d'actualité au coeur des
préoccupations des décideurs locaux
c'est l'occasion par exemple pour les
maires franciliens à d'échanger sur les
difficultés dans leur commune questions
budgétaires 25 % de logements sociaux
imposé par la loi sru ou encore attentes
des habitants de plus en plus exigeante
ce sont les problématiques rencontrées
au quotidien par les maires des îles
il a un entretien réalisé par nicolas
landry et patrick jacques de dixmude le
22e salon des maires d'île de france
vient d'être inaugurée en présence du
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
jacques mézard et la présidente de la
région ile de france valérie pécresse
un événement qui rassemble les 1300
maires des communes de la région qui
permet de créer des échanges entre les
acteurs privés et les acteurs publics
dans un contexte où les mères
connaissent de nombreuses difficultés
actuellement en compagnie de stéphane
beaudet le président de l'association
des maires d'ile-de-france donc
l'organisateur de ce salon
alors quel est l'intérêt de ce salon
pour les mères les 1300 maires des
communes d'île de france s'intéresse
nombreux d'abord de démontrer qu'il n'ya
pas de réformes dans un pays comme le
nôtre sans les maires parce que les
mères des inventeurs du quotidien
deuxième élément c'est évidemment les
changes des bonnes pratiques quand on
est inventeur dans son coin
c'est mieux de le faire savoir en
échange les bonnes pratiques puis
troisième élément c'est aussi de montrer
que les maires se modernise que les
maires en temps des messages que les
mères participent du désendettement de
l'état mais que les maires disent aussi
tout en réinventant le modèle communal
il faut nous écouter nous ne sommes rien
d'autre que le reflet des aspirations de
nos habitants qui n'aspire à sion qui
change
on voit la pression en voit tous les
maires qui qui démissionne au bac ce
mandat est de plus en plus dur donc on
est aussi là pendant trois jours pour
dire on est debout et on va résister en
les communes innove notamment hier le
maire de maurepas grégory jarry astier
et le maire de jean-pierre sevestre le
maire de coignières ont annoncé vouloir
former une commune nouvelle est ce que
c'est une solution pour justement faire
face à ces problématiques
la commune nouvelle on sait c'est une
solution presque 600 communes nouvel
enfant sur les trois dernières années
c'est à dire 1900 commune en moins sont
personnes s'en rendre compte
j'ai moi-même avec francis oies et
vrilles annoncé pour éveil courcouronnes
aux voeux il ya quelques semaines que
nous fusionnons et créer une commune
nouvelle
evry courcouronnes au 1er janvier
prochain je crois qu'il ya un projet
également
germain en laye donc on voit que cette
réalité se rapprochent baisse de
notation d'un côté on aura le pouvoir
des maires dans des agglomérations de
plus en plus grande la commune nouvelle
devient évidemment une solution à la
fois de reprise de pouvoir à l'intérieur
de l'agglo demain il y aura d
agglomération forte mais elle ne vivront
que si à l'intérieur il ya des communes
qui sont fortes et en même temps c'est
la capacité technique par
l'harmonisation par la mutualisation de
redéployer du service public pour les
habitants
comme vous le voyez le salon des maires
d'île de france c'est l'occasion pour
les acteurs publics d'échanger avec des
partenaires privés que ce soit des
entreprises ou d'autres types de
structures et nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des maires civile ynwa pour
voir comment eux ils font face aux
problèmes dans le cadre de leur mandat
en compagnie de pascal thévenot le maire
de vélizy le maire républicain alors
quelles sont les problématiques face
auquel vous vous êtes engagés
actuellement en tant que maire on va la
province d'ica les budgétaires
c'est on a beaucoup de projets encore à
vélizy j'ai la chance d'avoir une
économie dynamique avec des nouveaux
sièges qui arrive d'année en année donc
à compenser toutes les pertes mais moi
si vous voulez un en quatre ans
j'ai perdu toute ma dotation de
fonctionnement donc l' avantage comme je
suis toujours positif c'est que j'ai une
vie fiscalement autonome donc ces voix
là je ne suis plus à l'écouté des
baisses plus ou moins important de jeu 0
voir une fiscalité négative en fait
puisque
l'état me prend même sur la fiscalité
locale donc là c'est la problématique
qu'on a c'est surtout ça autres maires
présents avec nous jean claude husson le
maire socialiste de la commune rurale de
saint-arnoult bonjour monsieur le maire
bonjour alors ok pour vous quelles sont
les difficultés auxquelles vous faites
face au quotidien en tant que maire dans
les yvelines
waze est toujours comme beaucoup de
maires là
les questions financières et puis aussi
le nombre d'obligations par la loi
certes les lois sans pile avec à chaque
fois des contraintes supplémentaires
c'est ça la première difficulté
près de 250 exposants sont présents ici
pour cette 22ème édition du salon des
maires d'île de france notamment des
acteurs privés partenaire des communes
comme des aménageurs urbains ou des
opérateurs téléphoniques et je suis en
présentant avec l'un d'entre eux hervé
gay qui est directeur général de sita
llose bonjour bonjour alors si tu a lieu
c'est l'aménagement urbain commun au
département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine en quoi consiste votre
activité en fait alors notre activité
consiste à mettre en oeuvre les projets
des collectivités les projets urbains
des projets de toutes tailles puisqu'on
a à la fois des grandes opérations comme
un vrai à poissy ou de petit tout petit
chose un peu compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre et donc les collectivités font
appel à nous à notre savoir faire pour
faire en sorte que leur projet voit le
jour
alors on sait que certaines communes
connaissent des difficultés notamment en
terme de deux finances locales une
baisse des dotations globales de
fonctionnement moins de recettes pour
les communes
est-ce que vous ressentez 7 cette baisse
des investissements des communes
yvelinoise 1 bien sûr nous nous la
ressentons tous les jours et c'est
quelque chose qui modifient profondément
notre façon d'agir puisque ça impacte ça
impacte les projets que nous réalisons
et pour cela nous développons de
nouveaux modes d'intervention en
intervenant directement sur des projets
en achetant des terrains en imaginant
avec les élus mais sans leur concours
financier des des opérations qui sont
celles qu'ils veulent voir réaliser sur
leur territoire et nous les mettons en
oeuvre directement grâce à notre
expertise et à nos à nos fonds propres
qui sont élevées qui nous permettent ces
interventions directes
près de vingt mille visiteurs sont
attendus durant ces trois jours sur le
salon la journée de mercredi sera
consacrée aux questions budgétaires
notamment avec une conférence sur la loi
de finances 2010 8 ou encore une
conférence sur la politique de la
jeunesse
la dernière journée du salon le jeudi 12
avril sera consacrée au numérique
l'élection doit se tenir en octobre
prochain les militants des républicains
des usines doivent choisir leur
10dans il y aura au moins deux candidats
face à pierre bédier président du
département alexandra du blanche
la conseil régional de 35 ans va faire
équipe avec un autre élu régional le
trappistes othman nasri pour je cite et
donner une nouvelle image du parti le
duo qui peut compter en tout cas sur le
soutien du maire de vélizy villacoublay
pascal thévenot
interrogé ce matin au salon des maires
d'île de france par nicolas landry
bah c'est une démarche en fait pour
joindre on a lancé un appel pour
finalement il n'ya pas de président au
niveau de la fédération des yvelines
naturel si une élection et que donc on
n'est pas en corée du nord
deux candidats ça semble le minimum
pour faire retrouver une dynamique et
plus tard autrement on décide qu'un tel
est président et ont fait pas
d'élections ce n'est pas
le sens des républicains et encore moins
de sens dans les yvelines pascal
thévenot qui fait partie tout comme
alexandra dublanchet othman d'un trou de
la centaine d'élus assignataire fin mars
d'une tribune contre pierre bédier pour
demander un renouveau politique dans les
yvelines l um à présent sur ce projet
innovant dont je vous parlais dans les
titres il a été développé par une
association et la fondation dassault
systèmes installés à vélizy une
collaboration pour créer une
bibliothèque anatomiques en trois
dimensions elle est destinée aux
étudiants de masso-kinésithérapie
malvoyants pour leur permettre notamment
de mieux se former et de favoriser leur
intégration professionnelle les détails
avec ce reportage de nicolas quirion
vite
cela peut paraître étonnant mais voici
des vertèbres lombaires imprimé en 3d
ces prototypes anatomiques ont été créés
par le groupement des intellectuels
aveugles ou amblyopes ils ont pour
objectif de soutenir la formation des
étudiants masseurs-kinésithérapeutes
malvoyants à la différence du
clairvoyant qui lui a la possibilité de
voir d'entrée de jeu dans son ensemble
pièces anatomiques le déficient visuel
n'a pas cette capacité donc il est
nécessaire pour lui de pouvoir la palper
l'étudier avec le grâce au toucher et de
pouvoir ensuite en la démonte en
apprécier l'ensemble de lance du contenu
d'une
d'une articulation en france 2009
praticiens masse au kinésithérapeute un
handicap visuel pour pouvoir développer
son projet le gia s'est associé à la
fondation dassault systèmes quand j'ai
reçu ce projet ça m'a semblé évident
parce que finalement l'impression 3d qui
s'appuie sur les mondes virtuels la
pression 3d permet de créer des outils
qui vont complètement révolutionné la
manière dont ces étudiants qui ont des
problèmes de vue qui sont déficients
visuels vont pouvoir apprendre de
nouvelles pièces 3d seront créés bientôt
principalement des articulations
ces outils pédagogiques seront
disponibles auprès du gia avant la fin
de l'année et seront accompagnées aussi
d'un support audio et de commentaires en
alphabet braille avec moi sur ce plateau
deux invités christian bézard bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable du
matériel spécialisé pour le comité
valentin hauy à des yvelines
l'association est au service des
aveugles et malvoyants avec nos
également catherine acquaviva bonsoir
vous êtes déficientes visuelles et
membres historiques de ce comité des
yvelines valentin hauy alors avant de
parler de cette conférence peut être une
petite réaction sur le sujet que l'on
vient de diffuser ce sujet donc ce sujet
sur cette bibliothèque en trois
dimensions qui permet à des étudiants
une meilleure intégration
professionnelle est ce que c'est un
projet christian bédard qu'il faut
encourager ce genre de projet alors
parfaitement le ballon tant au wild en
son sein une
mme école de kinésithérapeute donc
déficients visuels malvoyants ou non
voyants et je pense n'est ce pas
catherine que ça devrait pouvoir
intéresser les choses et les squelettes
en 3d existe déjà mais là c'est
peut-être plus détaillée j'ai
l'impression l'avantagent en fait il
faut savoir que le handicap visuel et le
handicap
le taux d'intégration professionnelle
est le plus faible donc tout ce qui peut
favoriser l'intégration dans le milieu
professionnel de personnes handicapées
visuelles et à favoriser de toute
manière alors je rappelle vous êtes une
membre historique de ce comité divine de
l'association valentin hauy qu'elles
sont telles sont les missions de cette
association
alors l'association en fait deux
missions principales la première c'est
de bd en fait les personnes qui perdent
la vue en les soutenant moralement je
dirais psychologiquement
et puis aussi en leur apportant des
formations donc leur fournir un maximum
d'autonomie retrouver un maximum
d'autonomie et le deuxième point c'est
de les empêcher en fait de s'enfermer
chez elle parce que quand on a eu
quelques problèmes sur le trottoir avec
des voitures des mobylettes la tendance
à rester chez soi et on perd tout
contact social donc un des objectifs de
l'association est de recréer du lien
social avec des activités culturelles de
loisirs et sportives et on peut le dire
un comité des yvelines dynamique 600
membres environ et plusieurs antennes à
travers tout le territoire comme celui
monde et les antennes donc saint germain
en laye mantes-la-jolie rambouillet on
est en train de développer une antenne
c'est tout nouveau c'est de ce matin
dans la saint quentin en yvelines en
train de chercher un local d'ailleurs
une annonce est faite voilà et puis les
mureaux également dans le sud yvelines
poil alors des antennes qui sont
efficaces et qui permettent aux
justement déficients visuels de ne pas
avoir à déplacer sur versailles de venir
au comité qui est le seul le centre
vital de notre association des actions
rendez vous aussi vous organisés comme
cet après midi à thématique samedi à la
rotonde à versailles son titre
déficience visuelle quel futur
un événement pour faire le point sur les
avancées technologiques et médicale pour
les déficients visuels alors avant qu'on
rentre dans le détail catherine
acquaviva
vous qui est déficiente visuelle est ce
que vous ressentez des progrès ces
dernières années sur ces technologies
qui peuvent peut-être améliorer votre
quotidien
parce que complètement de toute façon
tout ce qu'il ya développement
informatique de en premier lieu puis
maintenant technologique avec tout ce
qui est comment mémoire augmente et va
apporter en fait de l'aide dans
l'autonomie des déficients visuels
alors ce qu'ils appellent les gens
certifie ciel nous aide énormément
c'est très bien oui ça facilite le
quotidien le finalement la technologie
est au service
mais c'est à dire qu autrefois le
l'aveuglent avait le bras je vais être
tu es très schématique mais avait à sa
disposition une canne blanche et le
braille
aujourd'hui avec toute la technologie
qui existe on peut utiliser des
smartphones on peut utiliser des
ordinateurs on peut vraiment utilisé au
niveau technologique plainte de dead
quotidienne et c'est d'ailleurs
l'objectif du matériel du magasin que
nous avons au sein de l'association qui
propose du matériel spécialisé qui nous
aident dans la vie de tous les shows
justement des technologies qui lisent et
d'autres qui sont en projets vont être
présentés donc samedi lors de cet
après-midi thématique christian vézard
notamment la can connectés qui existe
déjà
c'est un principe qui existe déjà c'est
quoi son principe alors que jusqu'à
maintenant on a des cannes de détection
qui existe depuis un petit moment dons
qui permettent aux déficients visuels
dans l'espace de repérer les objets ce
qu'une canne blanche leur permet de
repérer les objets au sol mais pas en
hauteur donc une table dans le déficient
visuel va se prendre deux rescapés dans
la table voilà lé panneau et tout ce qui
est autour
et puis donc la cad connectés c'est une
canne qui et c'est un boîtier qui va
s'adapter sur la canne et qui va
permettre donc de se repérer ça peut
vous dire moment vous dit où suis-je ça
vous dit vraiment vous êtes vous avez un
gps intégré qui me permet de vous
déplacer dans le dans la ville où vous
êtes sa détecte les feux sonores
c'est vraiment tout à fait intéressant
puisque donc quand on veut traverser
pour un déficient visuel c'est très
compliqué se lâcher dans le sur une
traversée de rue et puis ça permet dans
les villes qui sont adaptés de repérer
les bus qui viennent dont savoir dans
quel premier temps ils seront là et
voilà donc ça c'est le sait ce qui
existe actuellement
il ya un projet ça sera également
présenté un casque de réalité augmentée
pour est un peu plus d'une minute
elle est aussi d'accord donc le premier
casque audio de réel est augmentée pour
aveugles c'est un c'est une mise en
lumière qui change tout c'est ce qui le
titre de l'oeuvre de leurs ce site qui
met en lumière de manière vocale les
objets les textes que la personne ne
peut pas voir et la caméra du casque
panda film donc l'environnement
l'intelligence artificielle lui permet
de comprendre ce qu'il voit et de
décrire l'environnement sont porteurs
c'est ce qu'on appelle la réalité
augmentée auditive c'est un peu une
voiture autonome autour du cou donc on a
en a de cette façon bon là c'est en
projet c'est on va on l'est on les
connaît depuis l'année dernière nous
étions au congrès avait atteint l'an
dernier de la start up parisienne de
lettres se crée et là ils sont dans les
starting blocks
ils sont vraiment où ils vont et
efficient on est vraiment dans les eaux
on est au bout du bout et je crois que
ça va arriver alors le temps de cet
entretien malheureusement écoulée mais
je précise également qu'il y aura des
points sur les avancées en termes de
médecine et notamment par le professeur
jean-marc le geste sûr tu as fait sur
l'oeil
artificielle et là on était là les
artificiers un corner difficiel qui est
donc là qui existe déjà
donc lui c'est sa spécialité mondiale et
puis donc l'oeil artificiel pour les
tout ce qui est génétique et les grèves
de rétine quel grand espoir des
déficients visuels et toutes ces
informations vous pouvez bien sûr les
retrouver sur le site du comité des
yvelines valentin hauy merci à mes deux
invités d'avoir été avec nous à
catherine a choisi sans merci à
christian humbert bab zarand c'était
marqué bernard cieutat merci d'avoir été
avec nous un beau d'urbanisme à présent
la loi est claire d'ici 2025 les
communes devront avoir au moins 25 % de
logements sociaux il n'est donc pas rare
en ce moment de voir des lancements de
programmes d'immobilier comme ici à
villepreux la première pierre de ce
nouveau chantier a été posée
symboliquement vendredi dernier un peu
plus de 400 logements dont une centaine
en locatif social vont sortir de terre
d'ici mars 2020 c'est la deuxième phase
de la réalisation du nouveau quartier
des eaux du moulin entamé en 2014 avec
ses réalisations villepreux aura treize
mille habitants en 2020 soit 30 % de
population en plus en 12 ans écoutez le
maire de la commune
le premier objectif de ce programme
c'est de permettre aux habitants de
vivre heureux de poursuivre leur parc
leur parcours entre des logements plutôt
en maison vers du collectif ça c'était
vraiment le premier objectif le deuxième
objectif était très important c'est de
nous conformer à la loi sru et de
rattraper notre retard en logements
sociaux c'est ce que nous faisons avec
plus de 120 nouveaux logements sociaux
est actuellement villepreux dispose de
17 5 % de logements sociaux et ce n'est
pas dans les clous de la loi sru
en conséquence la commune payera une
amende cette année deux cent mille euros
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
rédaction elle représente les 790
avocats que compte le barreau de
versailles en début d'année et christine
blanchard masi a été élue bâtonnier sa
mission être en charge du bon
fonctionnement de l'un des plus
20 plus grand barreau de france et c'est
seulement la troisième femme à exercer
cette fonction rencontre signée aurélie
rose depuis le 1er janvier 2018 à
christine blanchard masi empruntent
quotidiennement ce petit couloir qui
mène à son bureau de bâtonnier titulaire
d'une capacité en droit
un diplôme d'état d'un niveau équivalent
à celui du baccalauréat elle fait ses
études à la faculté de sceaux dans les
hauts-de-seine
l'avocate prête serment à paris en 1993
puis intègre le barreau de versailles
deux ans plus tard la menthe judiciaire
était pour moi une fascination la
défense aussi est un métier qui
m'attirait au plus haut point et c'est
tout naturellement oui que je me suis
dirigé vers vers ce métier qui 25 ans
après toujours une passion spécialisée
dans le droit de la famille elle est
élue le 22 juin 2017 bâtonnier de
l'ordre des avocats de versailles son
mandat de deux ans se terminera fin
décembre 2019 avant elle seules deux
femmes ont accédé à cette fonction à
versailles en 1959 et en 1996 un honneur
pour christine blanchard masi c'est
comme dans tout domaine de la société la
femme doit prouver encore plus qu'un
homme pour accéder à des fonctions
deux directions donc les rôles des
avocats n'échappe pas à cette
problématique que rencontrent les femmes
mais c'est vrai que ça a été assez dur
il ya encore un état d'esprit
assez misogyne mais dans l'ensemble j'ai
été élu de façon extrêmement confortable
des larges ce qui me donne une
légitimité certaine chef des 790 avocat
qui composent le barreau de versailles
son rôle est multiple veiller à ce que
chacun respecte ses obligations en
termes de déontologie en termes de
formation s assurer que les droits des
avocats soient respectées mais aussi
gérer les litiges fait quelqu'un qui va
droit au but 1-1 qui avance et qui ne
recule pas et qui veulent aller de
l'avant sans arrêt moi ça fait comme ça
fait 20 ans que je suis là donc c'est la
première fois que on a une femme et lui
de bateliers effectivement en sachant
quand même que le barreau est très
féminisée sont pourtant du barreau ça me
paraissait un peu normal que femmes sont
battues en plus de ses nouvelles
fonctions de bâtonnier christine
blanchard masi continue d'exercer son
métier d'avocat indispensable selon elle
pour rester en contact avec ses
confrères et les juges une profession
qui est malgré tout stressante
ce que nous apprend un séminaire des
dauphins les dauphins ce sont les
bâtonniers qui viennent d'être élus
pendant six mois qui suivent leurs
prédécesseurs avoir la prise de fonction
et donc au séminaire des dauphins on dit
la première chose respirez soufflez ça
c'est ce que je vais très souvent pour
pour reprendre mes esprits et me
concentrer vous plus sérieusement oui
je pratique du sport pour relâcher
durant son mandat christine blanchard
masi compte notamment mettre en place et
des outils afin d'améliorer la
communication avec le grand public
c'était une journée dédiée au secteur
rattrape la fête de la petite enfance
étaient au programme samedi dernier jeu
éducation tant d'informations avec des
professionnels ce rendez vous est devenu
incontournable pour les habitants
retour sur cette cinquième édition avec
nicolas landry et camille lambert
[Musique]
je
de simples bâtonnets de la colle et des
feutres à deux ans et demi c'est déjà
tout un univers et des techniques à
découvrir
monia est venu spécialement ici pour
partager un moment avec son fils c'est
bien pour lui pour moi ça permet de
développer beaucoup de choses chez
l'enfant
c'est un moment de partage parce que tu
es rencontres aussi deux enfants et puis
non en compte les professionnelles et
professionnels de l'enfance partager
autrement c'est le thème de cette
cinquième édition de la fête de la
petite enfance à trappes
une journée d'échangés entre parents
enfants et professionnels où le jeu est
mis à l'honneur le jeu vos parties de
l'éveil de l'enfant il est très
important de partager ce moment avec eux
on a une vie qui s'accélère de plus en
plus hélas on a de moins en moins de
temps pour les petits bouts tout donc
c'est un moment qu'on apprend à partager
que son enfant il y a
à goal relaxation où on apprend à
partager avec son bébé sans l'enfant
plus grans des moments de détente ceux
qui sont très importants un ballon une
petite balle molle souple ou une petite
voiture justement faisant des mouvements
tout doucement sans remonter en
descendant en fait d'éteindre la
personne
la ville compte une vingtaine
d'assistantes maternelles publiques avec
ce type d'événement elle espère
sensibiliser les parents mais aussi les
futurs parents de la commune
et puis un mot de ce sport promue l'an
passé le sky rugby évoluera bien encore
en division honneur la saison prochaine
ce week-end le club a validé son
maintien dans le championnat une
victoire 29 à 14 face au club ministère
finance paris le résumé du match avec
michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry
ce dimanche 9 avril le sky rugby joué sa
survie dans le championnat de division
honneur à domicile face à ministère
finance paris un match à enjeu qui n'a
pas tétanisé le promu dès les premières
minutes de la rencontre les saint
quentinois mettre du rythme et remporte
la première période 17 à 7
avec deux essais inscrits raconté
c'était de se faire plaisir malgré la
pression du maintien
maintenant on voit que il ya un vrai
objectif parce que l'intensité est
vraiment présente au retour des
vestiaires le ska et rugby continue sur
sa lancée les bleus réalisent un 100% au
pied en seconde période grâce à jus du
rouleau b reste la faille pour
l'emporter 29 à 14 au coup de sifflet
final
ce collectif l'équipe l'équipe va bien
marcher devant derrière c'est bien
connecté était propre
avec cette victoire les saint quentinois
sont assurés de terminer à la huitième
place sur dix équipes engagées avec
quatre points d'avancé sur manque limer
le premier relégable le staff se
projette déjà sur la saison prochaine
il faut pas rajouter une seule chose
fonctionne ajouté plein de petites
choses pour que ça se passe bien
la fois être meilleur a physiquement
pour être meilleur que quelques joueurs
qui viennent un peu plus un peu plus
chanceux sur blessure parce qu'on a bien
chargé cette année en blessure donc donc
ça arrive mais l'an prochain on aura
peut-être besoin de moi de malchance là
dessus et après c'est toujours
progresser
c'est à dire que l'art match aller on a
fait en a fait trois victoires et et au
match retour on a fait 3 victoires + 1
nul donc c'est mieux
le sky rugby clôturera sa saison ce
dimanche 15 avril contre vincennes à
domicile en match en retard
l'occasion de préparer déjà la saison
2018 2019
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal merci
de l'avoir suivi excellente soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]